let's talk about a couple of those
philosophy arguments from 101
that are constantly trotted out i've had
similar experiences
the most common one that i've heard of
course is the problem of evil the
suggestion that
how can god be good if so much evil
takes place
in the world the more sophisticated
version of the argument to me is not the
problem of human evil which seems
pretty easily disposable but the the
problem of
natural evil things happening to
children a child with cancer how does a
good god
rule over a world in which children die
of of natural
causes in which kids are born with tay
sachs in which horrible things happen to
good people
yes in dealing with this problem i think
it's
really important that we distinguish
between what i call the intellectual
problem of evil and the emotional
problem of evil
there is no doubt that emotionally
the evil and suffering in the world make
it very difficult to believe
in god it's a tremendous emotional
obstacle
but intellectually considered
dispassionately
as a philosophical problem it's
extraordinarily difficult
to show that there's either any
inconsistency
or improbability between the existence
of an all-loving all-powerful god and
the evil and
suffering in the world the atheist would
have to show
that it is either impossible or
improbable
that god has morally sufficient reasons
for permitting the natural and moral
evil in the world
and how could he possibly show that
we're simply not in a position to make
those kind of probability judgments
with any confidence and so i think that
the problem of evil as difficult as it
may be emotionally
intellectually it lays a burden of proof
on the shoulders of the atheist which is
so heavy that it has proved to be
unsustainable
and these days the other argument that
is brought up an enormous amount
is the supposed backwardness of the
bible itself and biblical morality
this happens largely with regard to for
example
homosexual marriage uh it's been brought
up with regard to
abortion which i think is more again
easily disposable because i think
there's a solid secular argument in
favor of of protection of human life
but homosexual marriage is the one that
most often comes up you also hear
arguments that the bible permits slavery
uh so if the bible is so wonderful then
why are there all these weird sections
of the bible where it talks about wiping
peoples from the earth where it talks
about
where it talks about enslaving other
human beings some things that we would
certainly consider moral evils today
are contemplated by the bible and not
banned by the bible so why
why is that well let me address briefly
first this question of slavery
when we hear the word slavery ben we
think of
slavery as it existed in the american
south
and as you know that is nothing like
the system that existed in ancient
israel in ancient israel there was no
social safety net sponsored by the state
there was no poverty program so
if a man got himself into a situation
where he couldn't
pay his debts he could keep his family
together and retain his self-respect
by selling himself as an indentured
servant
to his creditor until he could work off
his
debts and then he would have to be set
free after
seven years he had to be set free in any
case
so this was really a form of indentured
servanthood it wasn't
slavery as we think of that term this
was actually an
anti-poverty program and in some
respects
i think it's better than what we have
in modern western culture which destroys
families
ruins people's self-respect because
they're not working
whereas in ancient israel a man retained
his
self-respect he worked for an income he
paid his debts he kept his family
together
and that to call that slavery is just a
gross misrepresentation
now the first thing you mentioned i've
i've forgotten homosexual marriage
with respect to some of these other
moral
questions
i think we need to remember the first
premise of the moral argument
if there is no god then there are no
objective
moral values and duties everything is
socio-culturally
relative so who's to say that the moral
values of a society
that discriminates against people and
oppresses people
is worse than one which is liberal and
tolerant we just sort of assume
that the the liberal values um are the
ones
that would be objective when in fact
they're just as relativistic
as any of the other ones on atheism so
if we need god to be the
anchor point for objective moral values
and duties
we cannot escape the question when
thinking of moral right and wrong
well what does god think of this and if
god
proscribes something it seems to me
that's entirely
within his right if god were to say
thou shalt not eat beans or thou
shalt not eat pork that would be our
moral duty
and we should obey it that is his
prerogative as the moral law giver
and the supreme good and so if god says
my plan for human sexuality is
heterosexual marriage
that's his prerogative and there is no
basis for calling that
i think into question so let's talk
about the evolution of morality and i
want to go back to slavery for just a
second so it is true
that that hebrew enslavement the jewish
enslavement of others is really more
indentured servitude
and there's a whole section in i believe
it's it's numbers or leviticus i think
it's leviticus maybe
where it speaks to specifically about
the slave who doesn't want to leave and
you're supposed to pierce his ear on the
doorpost
as a punishment for him not wanting to
leave in all of this um
but by the same token
enslavement of people who are not inside
the the
israelite inside the jewish kind of
tradition that's
not proscribed so the idea of war
captives is obviously
taken into account and not banned so
certain things are banned in the bible
certain things are not bad now the way
that biblical believers
have practiced over time is that very
early in the church's history they're
already starting to eliminate slavery
although not for people who are captured
and then over time
the west is the first place to eliminate
slavery altogether
specifically citing the sections of the
bible that talk about human freedom and
the innate value of every
human being so is that an evolution of
morality or is that a realization of a
fundamental principle
that was originally given to people who
couldn't necessarily understand the full
extent of the principle well i think i i
think it's the latter and i
love the way you put it i think that's
nicely put
jesus said something very much like this
with respect to
old testament regulations on divorce
they asked him whether or not it was
lawful to divorce a woman for any reason
and jesus said
moses allowed you to write a certificate
of
of divorce but it was not so from the
beginning
and he cites then the creation story of
genesis
of adam and eve and said what god has
put together
let not man put asunder so what jesus
was saying there was that
the law of moses was a temporary uh
prescription accommodating the hardness
of heart of the people at the time
but it didn't represent the perfect will
of god
for human marriage which was grounded in
the
creation story so how exactly do we
determine
when we have moved beyond the biblical
text in terms of the evolution of that
morality when are we fulfilling
uh a broader goal that was that you know
was
kind of held back by temporary
constraints and when
are we moving utterly beyond it and
again here i'm thinking of same-sex
marriage so
when it comes to same-sex marriage the
argument is now being made by people
in liberal churches including including
pete buddy judge who's running for
president
that basically jesus was seeking equal
respect for
everyone he cared about the least of
these and the prescriptions on
homosexuality
were really more and homosexual activity
were not eternal precepts but were
really
attempting to crack down on the the
promiscuity of the time or they were
temporary expedients yeah i i think
that's clearly false
when you look at these uh regulations
both in the old testament and then
they're repeated
in the new testament in the strongest
terms in romans chapter one 1.
there's no doubt that paul is thinking
of this as
a moral law that has abiding
significance and it's grounded again
i think in the creation story that god
has created human sexualities created
man and woman
uh in such a way that the fulfillment
of that relationship will take place
within the safety and security of a
heterosexual
marriage and that outside of that
sexual activity is not to be indulged in
and this is a
law that god has given us for our good
so i do not think that this
is capable of simply being relativized
to time and culture
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content